[Music]  there's more to life than your farm owen  he needs to see that there's a whole  galaxy out there i am asking you  to leave us alone ben i mean it  is he  you don't care if he's okay  you care if he's showing my  responsibility owen i'm his uncle we  talked about this when the time comes he  must be trained like you trained his  father  they're coming  stay hidden  or we will not survive  [Music]  leave us alone when the time comes he  must be trained  like you trained his father  you still want  kenobi he's gone  [Music]  maybe you've been looking in the wrong  places  i want every lowlife and bounty hunter  to squeeze him  you can't write all we want  you can't escape him  [Applause]  [Music]  you